hello everybody Doug Walker here without
my brother this week he is out of town
so it's unable to see the movie and
we're not able to a sibling rivalry but
the next time a big movie comes up you
know we'll do it then
but I know you're hungry for opinions so
this is my opinion on Oz the great and
powerful as the Sam Raimi's latest flick
and a premie I'll go quickly to a story
just a quick summary if you don't know
stars Larry Franco as oz from Kansas
he's a magician slash kind of a conman
you know like the good art akan man gets
whisked away by a tornado into the Land
of Oz which is confusing seeing how his
name is Oz and if this really is a real
world thing by the way and it's not a
dream which they're indicating in this
one it's how does husband work how does
it incorporate these things like you
know the world will exist based on
certain things around this person it's
very confusing but on top of that
there's a prophecy so maybe everything
was planned from the very beginning you
know the prophecy of of course the
chosen one who will come down and bring
order and balance to the land
so Larry Franco lands in Oz and he
pretty much comes across Mila Kunis who
plays one of the witches and her sister
Rachel Weisz her British sister that
looks nothing like her I think I say
that the bumper View but that that's
really distracting and they pretty much
tell him that he is the chosen one he's
gonna bring order in balance and order
to do that you need to defeat the Wicked
Witch who's over on the other side of Oz
go kill her so he sets off on that
adventure and what a shock he comes
across colorful characters along the way
who join him in his quest and there's a
couple twists and turns here and they're
not big ones you know mainly obvious
ones but you know but they're in there
and I won't give it away and actually
the big thing I'll say early on is that
because the movie does look good and if
you're watching it from the beginning
with the black and white stuff and the
the square ratio which is very clever
and when you get
two odds if you think yourself well this
looks kind of muted and not as awesome
as I thought wait there actually is a
reason why the Emerald City doesn't look
as colorful and it's the really colorful
really visually holy this is
beautiful stuff is coming so if you're
watching the movie and you get to that
point you're like oh man what a letdown
it's like there's good visual stuff
coming so you know it hold out for it
but with that said there is some stuff
that's really really cool in this movie
I mean not just visually I think the
story in this movie like this is a
really good solid story like just when I
was looking at the problems they had out
saying myself know that the layouts
great I don't know how much it follows
the original book or even I know there's
several Oz books I don't know if one was
about how he came to Oz but it's just a
good setup and everything seems to fall
into place for when the other movie The
Wizard of Oz comes along for the most
part of everything really seems to fall
into place from what I've noticed that
still flowed like a good story so the
story I think is wonderful the big part
that really like just bombs a good chunk
of this movie really sad to say the
acting is not really good I'm not really
a huge fan of James Franco but he could
act you know
um Larry Franco James Franco oh god it's
whatever its name is I apologize it's
late I just got done shooting the bum
review excuses excuses
ah so calm Oz I've seen him act and
other stuff and I'm a huge fan but I
cannot just be he can act then he's
trying you can tell he's trying you know
he's not Russell crowing it you know
when you look at him weights not talking
he's really when he's worried he gets
the big worried eyes and everything so
he's definitely really trying here um
but it's sort of like Leonardo DiCaprio
where I always sort of see this young
guy trying to play an older guy or
trying to play something that clearly
he's not and some people can pull it off
I mean acting is not always easy
especially trying to play so against
what you normally are um and here it
just doesn't work and I think a good
tongue of the time it's just kind of
awkward you know he just looks like a
young man you know trying to play a
magician which you could argue well
that's why it is but his yelling is kind
of weird and he's he doesn't quite add
the charm that I think this character
should have AI see more like like a Hugh
Jackman or an Edward Norton in this role
you know someone has this real charm and
charisma you know he's supposed to be a
con artist you know essentially a
magician he's supposed to be an
illusionist and we're Norton what's the
illusionist so that would make sense so
you got that Rachel Weisz is okay you
know I mean nothing spectacular um but
the one that really oh man
Mila Kunis in this movie first to her
credit it's not the best written
character like from a story perspective
it's a good character like oh wow you
can really develop this and make her
interesting and complex um but the way
it's written especially in the opening
when she suddenly declares her romance
for the odds character and that she's in
love and what's to be his queen just
sore about of nowhere um maybe that
maybe that's supposed to be like
enjoyably awkwardly intentional you know
where it's like well yeah it's weird
that she would do this that's part of
her charm if it was man that doesn't
come through the performance in she it's
the first half of the movie it just
seems like she's not there I mean you
know that she'll be saying her lines but
there's just not much emotion in them
and then you get to the point I don't
want to give it away but she she really
has to stretch her acting chops and she
has to go to this she has to go to this
part in her character that requires a
lot in a sense I mean and some people
are very good at doing that some people
are very natural at it and again she can
act
I know she can I've seen her in drama in
comedy she is good she cannot pull this
off and it is beyond awkward seeing her
try to do this it requires a lot of
screaming and yelling some people are
very good at screaming and yelling but
those who aren't look really
uncomfortable and really weird and it's
oh and the makeup on her when they when
she gets into this part is not
impressive enough especially for Sam
Raimi and then they keep her in shadow
and they build her up here just like oh
what's it gonna look like and it's it's
not that bad I'm expecting Green Goblin
you know I mean even that looked
ridiculous but I mean that looked that
was over-the-top
compared to this makeup and this is
supposed to be over-the-top makeup now
later with Rachel Weisz you see later
they go right back to the great Sam
Raimi makeup I mean it's like something
out of Evil Dead it's a quick scene but
it's like yeah why didn't why didn't
they do that that would have been great
but they don't do it and the acting I I
think to myself that some directors must
just have a way of directing that you
know brings out certain performances you
know like I think of George Lucas
whenever he directs the performances are
usually not that good and a lot those
people are good actors or Shyamalan you
know now shall Allah that's the dialogue
it's just not good dialogue but again
there is sort of this style to the
acting that comes out and takes good
actors and just isn't that great you
know turns him into something that's
kind of mediocre Raimi has directed
actors and made them good and the one
I'm thinking of his simple plan
unbelievable movie by far as best of a
haven't seen it wonderful performances
the gift he directed that wonderful
performances uh I don't know what
happened it's like as soon as he got
into spider-man uh everything just went
really hokey it's like he went right
back to the evil dead hokey days and I
don't know if it's a time issue
who or what but something about the
acting in the movies just comes off as
really I don't say stilted just
something's a little off and I don't
know what it is I don't know how to fix
it but it's never quite right with the
exception of one character and I'd say
two characters the Zach Braff plays a
monkey in this which may annoy some of
you I etre thought I was okay if I
Dupree decent but the other character
this character steals the show
is the little China girl there's a girl
made out of China in this and just from
the moment she appears I mean first of
all beautiful effect I mean for the most
part it looks like she's there though
they never get the a time to pick her up
and ever looks like they really pick her
up but the the reflection on her looks
wait the expression on her looks great
the actress that got the player was
great any time she popped up in this
movie it's just like it's like a Wizard
of Oz movie is just like oh I mean it's
just so likable this thing um so I was
really really impressed with that I want
to see more of that there's a scene
where you know there she says she wants
to come along on the journey so now you
got you got Oz you got the little China
girl and you have the monkey and I'm
like this is what sort of Oz you know
this feels like you know Wizard of Oz
you know not exactly the same but kind
of updated and a different kind of story
and anytime a Sora did that it was doing
well there's a scene where one of the
witches puts them in bubbles you know
and they're going across the sky in the
pretty skies and there's rainbows and
this kingdom the month of munchkin
Kingdom whatever is in this giant bubble
and it's really pretty really likable
really imaginative and anytime they did
that stuff it was great the parts where
it gets really just monotonous and slow
is anytime they're doing something in
the story where you know exactly what's
gonna happen you know that you know when
the wizard is when oz is going to leave
and they say you can't leave it's yeah
one of you is really gonna leave yeah
it's just gonna take off and that's
gonna be the end of the movie right no
something has to convince him to stay or
how about when it looks like
you know it's gonna happen again a he's
going to leave them all behind and he's
the traitor and they all say I knew we
shouldn't have trusted him and then you
think he's dead and everyone's moping
and it's really stretched out and it's
just like dude we've seen this a million
times you know and okay I understand you
gotta do it you know is sometimes in
this story like I said I think it's a
good story
I think it's a good setup for his
stories so I understand you gotta go
through this but oh come on can't you
speed it up I mean the part where they
think he's dead I mean people are just
sitting there and holding each other and
oh Jesus look at your wizard he's dead
I'm like get off with it and there's so
many scenes like that when there's one
or two scenes where I'll give the movie
credit where sometimes the emotional
bits do work like early on the best some
of the best stuff is in the opening when
it's black and white you know there's a
scene where he's having a conversation
with with this woman who I hate someone
proposed to her and they used to have a
thing and it's it felt pretty good and
it was quiet and there was no music and
it felt very genuine there's a what the
introduction the little China girl I
mean it's just wonderfully touching
scene and it's so well handled you know
it remind me of when this a man comes to
live in spider-man 3 I mean it's like in
a sense that's sort of what this is like
you know it is sort of like the
spider-man movies we just have these
really wonderful you know not just
visually interesting but emotionally
well-done scenes and then you just have
others where it just drags so long and
it's so slow and it's you know what's
gonna happen and the acting is awkward
and weird and it's so okay and the
bottom line who would like this movie if
you're a big fan of The Wizard of Oz
you'll probably like the story if you're
not too picky about it you know and
you're a big oz fan and you just sort of
want to see an oz ish movie uh you like
it okay if you're looking for some eye
candy you know and some inventive
I don't want say effects but it
inventive ideas in terms of telling the
story cuz like I said that the the
opening is very clever and the opening
credits are very clever and then some of
the ideas about Oz are very clever you
know if you're looking for something I
can have very industrious moments you'll
give them sometimes you got to hold out
for him but you know they're there I'd
say people wouldn't like it if you're
really thinking this is gonna be like
the original Wizard of Oz without know
who really is but if you're thinking
like yes this is gonna take me right
back to my childhood probably won't
others to me distracting moments if
you're looking for good performances
don't go here I hate talking like that
because it looks like they're trying but
it's they just really don't come across
and yeah it's not really much of an
action film if you're looking for a lot
of good visuals there are some good
visuals but it's not throughout the
whole film like I said some moments
they're kind of muted my overall opinion
I'm very split on it because like I said
some parts it's just so cool and so you
know some parts did sort of make me feel
like a kid again like I said the
introduction of the the China girl I
thought was very well done but other
parts are just it's a little too awkward
for me I can't quite say I regret it
seeing it but I regretted seeing lots of
it like there's just enough scenes where
I'm like okay I'm I guess I'm justified
that I'm glad I saw it but just yes
barely um so yeah I guess in the future
I want to Sam Raimi keep trying new
stuff I like it when he tries new stuff
and different angles and different ideas
whatever you was doing in the gift and a
simple plan though may I start doing
that again cuz he got some kickass
performances out of those movies you
know and he can direct them he can do
all this I mean it's he's proven himself
over and over but yeah now we're so
again these big-budget movies are
supposed to require real emotions and
we're Sur getting the emotions of like
the Evil Dead movies you know that's
that's not what you need it's cool for
something like drag me to help you no
because that's essentially evil dead for
you no but when you get the stuff like
this yeah some about the performances
somes got be stepped up but yeah that's
my thoughts on it I hope everything is
well with you guys then I'll talk to you
later